♪♪
Good evening.
Welcome to the table.
My name is Kelly.
I am so thankful to be here with you tonight and to those online.
Hello.
We're glad you're here.
If this is your first time visiting,
I know it can be so scary to show up to a new place.
I'm so grateful for that.
I'm honored that you would choose to spend your time, space,
energy here.
I have a few announcements.
It won't take long.
So our church has what's called meet-up groups,
which is essentially like a small group, home team,
community group.
You get the gist.
And there's a new one meeting next week.
They're going to be having brunch.
So January 27th, it's the gray herring group.
Sage, you can sit wherever you want.
That's a good spot.
So if you're interested in that, you can fill out,
as you leave to the right, there are little cards.
You can fill out information there.
You can find me after church and ask.
You can find Brett.
You can find anyone, and we can definitely plug you in.
That group is for, like, 20-somethings
or fresh out of college or just graduated high school,
going into college.
So if you're looking to plug in and you're in that age group,
that would be a great group for you.
My other announcement, February 12th, Super Bowl Sunday.
Go Cowboys.
I can't wait.
So in honor of the Super Bowl and everyone
getting home in time to watch the commercials
and the halftime show, we are going
to meet at 4 o'clock instead of 5 o'clock, February 12th.
So put that on your calendar.
And I'm going to kind of switch gears
as we enter into a time of worship
and hearing the beautiful sermon that's
been prepared for tonight.
Some of you may have heard there was another shooting
in California, and they were celebrating
the Lunar New Year, which, I mean, there are just no words.
And I just thought we could, as a community,
take a moment to pray over them and have a moment of silence
and just all of the communities who live in fear,
who are harboring hate instead of love,
and just the ways that we deeply need
Jesus to pour out over and heal.
And after I get done praying, I'm going to light this candle.
It's going to be lit throughout the service
just as a token of remembrance and honoring that community.
So as you look at it, as the flame flickers,
may it be a reminder to honor those lives
and to pray for the families, the people who showed up
and helped, and the people who are severely
traumatized by that event.
So if you will, bow your heads with me.
I'm going to read this prayer, this reflection.
May you just take a deep breath in and let that out
and just be with me in this moment.
Christ, you wept over this city.
We are in deepest despair as we weep over the dead
and injured, killed by guns.
In anguish, we recognize the bloodstains of hatred.
We hear the sounds of fear, the echoes of gunshot,
once again, once again.
Christ, you came to bring us peace.
We turn to you in overwhelming sorrow.
How can we end this nightmare of violence?
How can we build a world of inclusion, of solidarity?
Give us the grace to reflect deeply and to work ceaselessly
to heal the hearts, to stop the guns,
to cherish all God's children.
Christ, you endured violent suffering to bring us light.
We pray for the dead.
May they rest in peace.
We pray for the wounded.
May they find healing.
We pray for our nation.
May we end the hate.
We pray for our global family.
May we learn that we are one.
In Jesus' name, amen.
Amen.
Thank you, Kelly.
That was beautiful.
Would you guys stand with me as we begin to worship together?
And I hope that you feel room and space
to bring everything that's on your heart
tonight into our worship.
And just lay it out before God, knowing that he sees us,
that he is with us, and he's for us.
And let him meet you wherever you're at tonight,
whether it be high or low.
He is the God who is with us.
So let's just sink our roots down into that truth
and feel him here.
I'm just going to name that and be up front about it
because that was awkward, and it's on me.
When you're drumming, it's helpful to know which song
that you're starting with.
What?
Glorious Day.
That is the song we're starting with.
Here we go.
I was buried beneath my shame.
Who could carry that kind of weight?
I was breathing but not alive.
All my failures I tried to hide.
It was my turn to look at you.
You called my name, and I ran out of that grave.
Out of the darkness into your glorious day.
Your mercy has saved my soul.
Now your freedom is all that I know.
Behold, they knew Jesus when I met you.
You called my name, and I ran out of that grave.
Out of the darkness into your glorious day.
The weight of your glory.
I needed shelter.
I was an orphan.
Now you call me a citizen of heaven.
When I was broken, you were my healing.
Now your love is the air that I'm breathing.
I have a future.
My eyes are open.
This way you call my name, and I ran out of that grave.
Out of the darkness into your glorious day.
You called my name, and I ran out of that grave.
All right.
Nicely done.
I like hearing you kids singing out in the front.
You kids are dismissed to go to your class.
And today, again, we're going to be up here all together
in this front classroom.
You guys are going to finish what you started last week.
Thank you to our kids ministry workers every week
who take time to be in there with these little ones
and serve them so tirelessly.
So grateful for you guys.
We're going to move into the prayers of the people,
and Jo's going to lead us in that tonight,
so you guys can follow along with her.
For the city of Saxe, Texas, and for every city and community
and all who live in them, we pray to you.
For the good earth you have given us
and the wisdom and will to conserve it, we pray to you.
For the old and the sick, for the widow and orphan,
for the injured and suffering, we pray to you.
For the poor and the oppressed, the unemployed and destitute,
for prisoners and captives, and all who remember
and care for them, we pray to you.
For the vulnerable, the marginalized,
and those unjustly targeted for their gender, sexuality, race,
or other perceived differences, we pray to you.
For those experiencing loss, loneliness, and disconnection,
and for those struggling with mental and emotional health,
we pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us, that you hear us,
and so we lift these names and situations up to you.
For the names and moments we have spoken aloud,
and for those we have kept in our hearts,
we pray to you that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
You are my joy.
You are my soul.
You are the wealth, the power, and the strength.
You are my life.
You are my wealth, the one I'm drawing from.
You are my refuge, my whole life long.
Where else would I go?
Surely my God is the strength of my soul.
Your love defends me, and when I feel I'm all alone.
Your love defends me, Your love defends me.
Day after day, night after night.
I will remember, you're with me in this fight.
Although the battle, it rages on.
The war's already won.
I know the war's already won.
Surely my God is the strength of my soul.
Your love defends me, Your love defends me.
And when I feel I'm all alone.
We sing Hallelujah.
You're my portion, my salvation.
Hallelujah.
Surely my God is the strength of my soul.
Your love defends me, Your love defends me.
And when I feel I'm all alone.
Surely my God is the strength of my soul.
Your love defends me, Your love defends me.
And when I feel I'm all alone.
We sing Hallelujah.
You're my portion, my salvation.
Hallelujah.
Thank you God that we can rely and to depend on your love.
That it carries us through each season.
God would you call us back to who you created us to be.
Would you help us to connect tonight.
To the person inside of us who's just a child.
That can crawl up into the arms of someone who loves them.
Someone who sees them and knows them.
Like the love of a good parent, a good mother or father.
Could we run to you?
Could we look to you tonight?
Can't beat a burden, too long on my own.
I wasn't created to bear it alone.
I hear your invitation to let it all go.
And I see it now, laying it down.
I know I need you.
I run to the Father, I fall into grace.
I'm done with the hiding, no reason to wait.
My heart needs a surgeon, my soul needs a friend.
I run to the Father again and again and again and again.
Oh, oh, oh.
I saw my condition, had a plan from the start.
A song for redemption, a price for my heart.
I don't have a context for that kind of love.
I don't understand, I can't comprehend.
I know I need you.
I run to the Father, I fall into grace.
I'm done with the hiding, no reason to wait.
My heart needs a surgeon, my soul needs a friend.
I run to the Father again and again and again and again.
Oh, oh, oh.
The heart has been in your sights long before my birth.
Running into your arms, running to life from death.
I feel this rush deep in my chest.
Mercy is calling out.
Just as I am, you pull me in.
And I know I need you now.
I run to the Father, I fall into grace.
I'm done with the hiding, no reason to wait.
My heart needs a surgeon, my soul needs a friend.
I run to the Father again and again.
I run to the Father, I fall into grace.
I'm done with the hiding, no reason to wait.
My heart found a surgeon, my soul found a friend.
I run to the Father again and again and again and again.
Oh, oh, oh.
God, we look to you today.
We look to you.
Thank you for the opportunity to be together,
to lift our hearts, to open up.
Would your love be the thing that finds us,
that roots us, that guides us?
In Jesus' name.
Would you guys turn to the people around you,
say hello, make them feel welcome,
and Brett will get us started on our message.
Hi, guys.
OK.
Hi.
Yes.
Thank you.
Hi.
Well, grace and peace, it is good to be with you all.
My name is Brett.
I think most of you know that.
It might be someone new.
I always just want to mention it.
I don't want someone to feel completely left out,
like, who's this guy?
So I'm Brett.
I'm the pastor here.
And it's just wonderful to be with you all.
So, so good.
And as always, I want to welcome those joining us online.
So glad to have you through the wonders of technology.
And then, of course, anyone here who's new,
maybe just finding your way into the community,
we're just really, really glad that you're here.
Just know, we don't want to be the us for no more church.
That gets weird and not very Christ-like either.
So we don't want to be like that.
So just know you're wanted.
You're welcomed here.
So we are in, let's see, this is kind of really,
I guess, part two.
Last week in our series titled Rooted, Grounded Discipleship,
it was really kind of a big introduction.
So in a way, this kind of feels like week one
because what we want to do in this series
is just jump into a few spiritual practices
and kind of just begin to unpack them.
Because at the end of the day,
and we'll get more into this next week,
but discipleship to Jesus, it's really something you do.
It's something you live.
And Christian faith is so much more than
simply a creed or something that you say yes to that.
Like some churches recite the Apostles' Creed,
kind of this condensed version
of some of the major doctrines of Christian faith,
which I agree with.
I love the creeds.
But at the end of the day, it's about our living.
It's about our living.
I mean, like Jesus was asked, right?
Like what's the most important thing?
Like how would you sum up all the law and the prophets?
He didn't say, well, I've got this real long creed for you.
What he said was loving, love God, love your neighbor.
And it's like, man, we could learn all the theology,
memorize the scriptures,
but as Paul talks about later in the New Testament,
if we don't have love, we're not learning to love God
and like heal that relationship.
And then from that, love others.
Like what are we doing?
What are we doing?
So that's really the kind of heart of this series
is to start to go deep into that
because it could be easy to say like,
yes, we should learn to love,
but then that just brings up the deeper question.
How do I do that?
What does that look like?
How am I formed into that kind of person?
And that's like, ooh,
well, that's where we come into spiritual practices.
And so we'll be touching on a number of them
throughout this series.
So with that in mind,
the title of my message tonight is How to Pray.
How to Pray.
And I want to kind of frame this message.
I've got three, well, two scriptures
and then a quote from theologian Sarah Coakley
kind of tying the two scriptures together.
Because we're covering two texts,
we won't go like a super deep dive into them.
Instead, what I'm mostly interested in
is the relationship between these two texts on prayer
and the way they seem to be,
not necessarily in contradiction,
but they seem to be kind of pulling against each other.
Or if it's like, well, if this is true,
well, then how is that also true?
So we're going to start.
This is Matthew chapter 6, verses 9 through 13,
probably the most famous passage on prayer
because it's from the Lord Jesus himself.
And in response to the disciples asking him,
how do we pray, teach us to pray?
He said, this then is how you should pray.
Our Father in heaven, hallowed be your name.
Your kingdom come, your will be done
on earth as it is in heaven.
Give us today our daily bread
and forgive us our debts
as we also have forgiven our debtors
and lead us not into temptation
but deliver us from the evil one.
If you spend any time in church,
you've probably heard that one.
So our second scripture is from the apostle Paul.
This is Romans chapter 8, verse 26.
Just one verse.
In the same way, Paul writes,
the Spirit helps us in our weakness.
We do not know what we ought to pray for.
Can you see how these are kind of in tension with each other?
Like, well, this then is how you should pray.
And then Paul admits,
yeah, but we kind of don't know what we ought to pray for.
He continues, but the Spirit himself
intercedes for us through wordless groans.
Now our quote.
This is from theologian Sarah Coakley.
It's a bit lengthy, but she is,
I think she ties these together so beautifully.
And honestly, she's one of the great
current Christian writers on prayer.
She's wonderful.
You have time later.
She can be a little academic,
but she's a wonderful theologian.
So she says this.
So Jesus' disciples asked him,
And they are given a set of fundamental petitions.
And then in a very profound passage in Romans 8,
so you can see where she's kind of drawing these two together.
Paul acknowledges that we do not know
how to pray or even what to ask for.
She continues,
I don't think these two passages are incompatible.
We know that Jesus spent a lot of time
seeking to be alone,
praying to his Abba.
Clearly, he didn't restrict his prayers
to punctiliar requests.
In other words, just asking for thing after thing
after thing after thing.
Which I think sometimes is where
people get very confused with prayer.
Especially the idea of praying for a while.
And you're like,
So you just want me to keep asking God for things?
For like hours?
I mean, sometimes people are called
to kind of like an intercessory type prayer.
But there, it tends not to be
quite as wordy as you might think.
She continues,
And indeed, the deeper one goes into the Lord's prayer,
the more one sees that the seemingly generic requests
he gives us, like,
Thy kingdom come,
summon up a whole way of displacing oneself,
waiting for something else to arrive.
It took me a really long time to realize this.
But I think that what seems to be
our sheer incompetence in prayer,
can anyone relate to that?
Just like, I am not good at this.
Which she gets to in just a second.
Our sheer incompetence in prayer
is actually the place where something is happening.
It is God's invading our willed vulnerability.
I think a lot of people try to pray and then give up.
They feel it just isn't right for them,
that they aren't good at it.
But prayer is not like riding a bicycle
or getting a good grade on a term paper.
It's something sui generis.
That's theological talk.
I think it's actually Latin.
For utterly unique or of its own kind.
Precisely because relating to God
isn't like relating to anything or anyone else.
That's the first and most important point.
We should always pray as we can,
not as we can't.
Now, I understand that's a lot.
She is, you can tell, she's a smart lady.
Lots going on there.
But what I want to do is,
I just want to spend some time
kind of reflecting on Matthew 6, Romans 8,
Coakley's quote.
So I have many, many points tonight.
I've got three insights.
And then at the end I want to get practical
on six steps on how to pray.
So we'll kind of break this down.
Hopefully you can see the connections
as I go with our text.
So insight number one, we'll jump in.
Prayer, both with and without words,
comes to much the same thing.
It's the quality of our attention
to the Holy Spirit and our presence
that matters most.
I used to think there was a vast canyon
between praying with words
and praying without words.
Like in my mind, to pray,
well, early in my life,
the only way I thought you could pray
was with words.
Probably because I was like
raised with Matthew 6.
I just thought like,
that's how you pray.
You teach us to pray,
you say the prayer.
You know, and then maybe
kind of add on your own stuff,
but that's the idea, right?
So I kind of had this one season in my life
that was the only way to pray,
was to be quite wordy.
I remember there was a time,
this is like such,
I call it my forgotten year
because no one knows about it.
I like, I had no witnesses.
I went away to school
for one year to South Carolina
and I mean, I was pretty,
I left family, friends, everyone.
So no one knows what was going on.
So in my forgotten year though,
I led worship at this very small church
and like Sunday, it was like,
you know, just a little side gig.
Like, you know, broke college student.
And there was the lady,
she walked up the first Sunday.
She's like,
you bring the Holy Spirit fire.
That's what she said.
And I was like, what?
And she invited me to pray.
She was like,
I mean, people in church circles
call it like a prayer warrior
or like someone called the intercessory prayer.
So she'd apparently been at this church praying.
I mean, it was like a super,
I mean, it was one of the churches where,
I would say probably smaller
attendance wise in the table,
but the church could seat 700 people.
You know, it was that kind of like,
I've led a church like that
where we used to meet in gymnasium,
not the table, but our previous church.
And that was kind of like that
where you could have 40 people in a gym.
It was hard.
And so it was that kind of place,
you know, but you bring the Holy Spirit fire.
And she invited me to pray.
And so we,
I don't know why I went,
but I was like, well, okay,
it seems like you should pray, you know?
So we would go up there on like Saturdays or something.
And she could pray,
I mean, for hours.
And I was like,
I have run out of words.
I don't know.
I don't know what else to say.
And I think that's, yeah,
so that's kind of how I often thought of prayer.
It's like, well, that's Matthew 6,
like just do that.
And pray with words.
Then later in my life,
I learned about more of a Romans 8,
a wordless prayer,
sometimes even a groaning prayer.
Prayer without words.
Kind of a,
I think of the Psalms,
be still and know that I am God.
Really just a prayer of pure presence.
Just an awareness of God.
You're there.
And I'm here.
And I'm present to you.
And when I really got into that,
I started to look down a little bit
on the word,
on the wordy prayers.
Because, you know, in my mind,
like to pray with words
was to be, you know,
active and busy-minded and,
you know, so wordy.
And I was just like, ah, I can't.
But here's the thing,
as I've just kept going,
you know how you go through like seasons in your life,
you know,
and like the pendulum swings.
You're like really into this
and then you're really into that.
You know what I mean?
But through it all,
you're kind of finding your way.
And that's kind of my journey.
Like just finding my way.
And the longer I've journeyed,
the more these have kind of converged.
Where in the end,
I've realized like to,
that the end point is the same.
It really is the quality
of your presence to God.
Like that's the main thing.
I don't think God's like,
oh, I wish you'd use better words, you know.
I don't think God's overly concerned with that.
Ultimately, it's about,
it's love.
It's love.
And I've also found
that one form of prayer
tends to lead into the other.
So, and this is something
Coakley mentions in her quote.
Where she describes how,
like for example,
praying with words,
say you pray the Lord's Prayer.
If you pray that long enough,
eventually you realize
what Coakley names,
that you do not know
what you are praying.
Like you think you know.
You're like, oh,
I'm praying for the kingdom to come.
Yeah, what does that mean?
You know, and that's a big question, right?
I mean, you have some idea,
but the further you journey into that,
you realize, oh,
I actually have no idea
what that means.
Like I think I know,
but I really don't know.
Or God, I mean,
that's quite a prayer, right?
Lord, your kingdom.
In other words,
your reality, God.
Come here.
What would that mean?
What would that change?
What would that invite me into?
What would that invite you into?
Right, can you see where
it's like, oh,
that's a big prayer.
I'm not sure what I'm praying.
Or God, your will be done.
I mean, it's easy to say.
You know, it's like,
oh, Lord, your kingdom come.
Your will be done.
Heaven give us day or day.
You know, you know.
Busy before I go to work,
so I got to hurry.
It's like those are big.
That's big.
So you can see where
a prayer with words,
it just might lead you
to a place of silence.
Where you might say,
Lord, your kingdom come.
And then find yourself
real quiet for a while.
And vice versa.
As you pray without words,
if you feel drawn to silence,
you might find that
from that place,
suddenly a yearning
comes over you
to speak
on behalf of yourself,
your community,
your family,
people you love,
the world.
Right?
In other words, Romans 8
can lead you into Matthew 6,
and Matthew 6 can lead you
back into Romans 8.
But whether you're praying
with or without words,
that's really neither here
nor there.
At the end of the day,
it's the main thing
is the quality of our attention
and our presence.
Now, I think this might
naturally bring up the question
which leads us to
insight number two.
You say, what on earth
do you mean by quality
of my attention and presence?
I'm so glad you asked.
So, part of why
we struggle at prayer
is because our default
mental mode
is mostly one of stress,
hurry, worry, and blurry.
Right?
In other words,
the quality of our attention
and presence
is quite poor.
This is why, for example,
I could, with the woman
at that church,
she invited me to pray.
This is why she just
adored those times.
Oh, my goodness.
Three hours to her
was nothing.
And I was like,
20 minutes in, like,
oh, my gosh,
how long are we going
to be here?
What was the difference there?
Well, she had been doing
that for 20 years.
And so, the quality
of her attention
and her presence to God,
for her, it was a feast.
It was a rich, rich time.
For me, I was a beginner.
And it was kind of a slog.
Right?
Can you kind of
see the difference there?
One way, well,
and let me come back
to that language of stress,
hurry, worry, flurry.
I do think certain
cultural influences
can kind of lend themselves
to people of prayer
or can kind of draw away.
And you have,
even to this day,
certain kind of cultures
that are so powerfully
influenced by their religion
that it's almost like
kind of in the air
and in the water,
so to speak,
of quiet and contemplation
and, you know, I mean,
I think, for example,
of maybe like Tibetan culture
with its Tibetan Buddhist influence.
They're just kind of
prayer kind of people.
You know?
Certain Indian influences,
like it's just
on the continent of India,
like it's just,
there's a certain culture.
I do think in the West,
although we have a powerful,
strong kind of roots
in Christian faith,
mostly the culture,
I don't think we're,
I wouldn't consider us
a super prayerful culture.
You know?
Quite the opposite.
We are a culture.
We're like the go people.
You know what I mean?
And even our religious practice,
like what are we awesome at?
Doing things.
You know what I mean?
Like you think of
kind of Western Christianity
and we're like,
we'll build your freaking hospital.
You're like, what do you need?
You need charity?
You need a non-profit started?
You need some,
you know, some energy?
Like, and by the way,
I'm not like saying,
oh, that's terrible.
That's wonderful.
Like that's part of the gospel.
That's beautiful.
You can see where we're like,
we're on comfortable ground there.
You know what I mean?
It's like, yes,
I know what to do.
You know, and I'll serve
and I'll do the thing.
And we're all of a sudden
when it comes to like,
well, let's just sit quietly
before God.
And we're like, oh.
Even if we've been in church
for 20 years,
we're like, I don't really,
I don't really do this.
Sit quietly before God.
It's not really my jam.
And just to name it,
I'm not saying that's like,
surprising.
Like, yeah, no, no kidding.
Like that's, it's the culture.
It's we really are the culture
of stress, hurry, worry, and flurry.
And that even makes its way
into the church to where
we're kind of all a flurry
even in our religious activity.
And this whole prayer silence,
this can be very challenging.
One way I often think of like,
what's a good way to indicate
or know what kind of mental mode
you're in?
And for me,
this might be helpful for you.
One thing I ask myself is,
and this isn't when you're praying.
This is like outside
of a time of prayer.
Right now, could I do a boring thing
by boring, I mean,
something super simple.
Could I do that without
another distraction at the same time?
It's like, for example,
I can tell what mental mode I'm in,
the quality of my presence,
if I have to, for example,
like do the dishes.
And do I, when I do the dishes,
sometimes I'm in like a good
head space, heart space,
and I can just like do the dishes.
But then other times,
I like need something else.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Like where you need,
like someone please turn on
the television or the radio
or the, you know what I mean,
like some sort of music
or a podcast or a something.
And of course,
there's times I'm not saying,
like if you were listening
to a podcast while you do the dishes,
that's a sin.
That's not my point.
I'm saying, you know,
if all of a sudden you found,
like your phone went dead,
if you would panic,
that's usually a sign
you're not in a super good place.
Does that make sense?
Because it's all,
it's similar with driving
is another great one.
Like when we're driving,
do we have to have that noise?
Like oh, turn it on.
Can't do this.
And why do we need the noise?
Why do I need the noise?
It's usually because there's feelings.
Feelings inside of me.
Do you have feelings?
I have feelings.
Right?
We start, and all of a sudden
when we come to a place
of prayer and silence,
that stuff tends to come up.
And it can be really,
really challenging.
There was a season in my life,
it was actually when we were
going through the process
of starting the table
and we were leaving
our previous church community.
And we were leaving,
I mean 20, 15, 20, 25 year
like relationships there.
Deep friendships.
Wonderful people.
But we did have reasons
for our leaving.
And there was theological struggles
and conversations.
Very emotionally tumultuous.
And it was probably
that because I'd spent some time
in doing some of these
spiritual practices and things
that I noticed,
I wish I could say,
and boy, I have never prayed more
than in that season.
But I can't really say that.
Instead what I noticed
is that I had never,
it was about a six month window,
I had never listened to more
sports talk radio and podcasts
than in that season of my life.
And why?
It was because I was in pain.
And so I didn't,
like to drive,
I couldn't just drive.
Uh-uh.
Needed the thing.
You know what I mean?
Couldn't just fold the laundry
or do the dishes
or whatever it was.
Like no, I needed the noise
in that season, right?
I was coping.
And again, just to be clear,
I'm not trying to judge it, right?
But it was good for me
to be aware
and to realize like,
ooh, this is gonna be a season
where prayer is gonna be challenging.
For some of you,
you might be in a season
where prayer is really challenging
because there's a lot going on
in here, right?
The head, the heart.
And what I would encourage you to do
is be gentle with yourself,
but at the same time,
press in.
Because it's often precisely
the things we need to work through, right?
All the things we're avoiding,
are often the things
like we need to work through.
In other words, to pray well,
I need to calm down
and slow down.
I must embrace stillness
and silence.
That leads to our third insight.
Pray as you can,
not as you can't.
That is right from Coakley,
there at the end of her quote,
of which I love this.
Pray as you can,
not as you can't.
You know, there may be a season
where you need the anchor
of words.
Matthew 6.
Like maybe even literally
the Lord's Prayer.
Like you pray that prayer
or some version of it
every day.
In fact, I think it's a good grounding practice
for Christians to really never leave
behind that prayer.
I think it's a very grounding,
orienting prayer.
But there may be a particular season
where the idea of just stillness, silence,
you're just like,
not my thing.
And that's okay.
But there may be a time
where you need Matthew 6.
You need the Psalms.
You need maybe other prayer books
that people have written
down through the centuries
where like you need to be given
the words to pray.
And like to that I say,
yes and amen.
Go for it.
And vice versa.
There may be seasons
where all of those words
either A, just don't resonate with you
in that time.
Don't connect with you.
Maybe you're even in a season
of deconstruction.
This is sort of what happened to me
and how I learned about silence.
I was in a season
where I was radically changing
so much theologically
that a lot of the language
of scripture and prayer
was really rubbing me the wrong way.
I was really struggling with it.
There were times where
I wasn't even sure if God was there.
So to try to pray the Psalms
or something I was like,
oh my gosh, I can't.
I just can't do it.
But in that season,
instead of just giving up
on God or prayer or whatever,
instead it was silence.
I would just close that door
and just sit quietly
and do nothing.
And then over time,
what happened?
Like I said earlier,
after like a year,
suddenly the words started
coming back to me again.
And now I kind of interweave them.
In other words,
just pray as you can.
Not as you can't.
If all you have
is five minutes of silence,
do it.
Go for it.
If all you have
is the Lord's prayer
in the morning and the evening,
wonderful.
I think we often get hung up
on the amount of time too.
If I was really holy,
I'd pray for an hour a day,
but I can't pray for an hour a day,
so I'm not going to pray at all.
We kind of set these weird standards
and bars and hoops to jump through.
Pray as you can.
Not as you can't.
So let's shift here
towards the end.
I want to wrap up with
how to pray.
Like maybe A,
maybe you've prayed for a while,
but you could use some freshness
in that routine.
Or B, maybe you're like,
I don't really do the prayer thing.
Maybe this could help you
kind of be an on-ramp.
So I'm going to give you six steps,
so they will go quick.
Don't worry.
Not 10 minutes on each.
Just a few minutes.
So step one,
wear your PJs
or other comfy clothing
and find a quietish place.
I realize this can sound
a little bit silly,
but really what I'm trying to get at
is do your best
to make prayer enjoyable.
Instead of,
I don't know,
it can get, I think at times,
overly formal or something.
You know what I mean?
Where it's sort of like,
there is something beautiful
about reverence,
but that I think is much more
about a heart posture before God
than making sure
you put on your Sunday best,
whatever that would mean at the table.
I'm not sure.
We don't really do,
we're not really a Sunday best
kind of place, you know.
But you know what I'm saying.
Like when we come to prayer,
like just be yourself.
Just show up simply as yourself,
just you and God.
Make the time enjoyable.
All right, step two,
sit, stand, kneel,
or lay comfortably.
You'll learn over time
what's best for you.
This might sound like I'm saying
posture doesn't matter.
That's not what I'm saying.
Actually, I do think people,
maybe especially in the kind of
Protestant evangelical world
that I came from,
it's sort of like, oh, you know,
posture doesn't care,
God doesn't care,
it doesn't matter.
Just do whatever.
And I agree and disagree.
I agree in the sense
that I don't think God's judging.
Like, oh, thou shalt kneel before me.
I don't think God's fine.
But here's what posture does,
is it does, it influences the body
which influences the mind.
And so, for example,
depending even on what type of
praying you're doing,
I think adjusting your posture
can be really powerful.
So, for example,
when I'm praying for others
or praying the Lord's Prayer,
I do enjoy kneeling.
At the same time,
I can't do that for an hour.
I don't know if you've ever tried
to like kneel for a long time,
at least without pads.
It can get painful, right?
So maybe if you're going to
sit in silence for a while,
maybe it's just sitting on a chair
like this with your back straight
and your palms open
and just something you can do
for a while, right?
Maybe hands raised, maybe hands up.
In other words,
what I want you to do is experiment
and try different postures,
different forms, different ways
and start seeing what's connecting
with you, what's working.
Step three, when you begin,
focus your mind and heart on God
say or think, here I am, Lord.
Here I am, Lord.
This comes back to quality
of your attention and presence.
Right here at the beginning,
you're setting your intention
and your attention, right?
Oh, that's right.
God, you're real and you're present
and you're there
and that's why I'm here
so that deep within me
can call out to deep within you,
God, and we can commune
and connect, right?
So it's just setting
that intention.
Step four, allow words, Matthew 6,
to lead into silence, Romans 8,
or vice versa.
Again, the exact style of prayer
less important than the quality
of your presence and you will find
one tends to lead into the other.
For years, I always started
with prayers for people
and then I went into silence.
Just recently, I've been reversing it
partly because I find
after a long time of silence,
or sometimes not so long,
but just some time of silence,
the quality of my attention
and presence is so different.
You come in like crazy,
especially if you pray in the evening
and it's been a crazy day
and you sit down and you're like,
okay, let me just run through
this list real quick,
pray for these folks.
You can see where it's just
like another to-do.
So there is something
about taking some time to like,
and then all of a sudden,
your prayers for your own self,
for others, like it's a,
that's a different experience,
but try different things,
feel it out, whatever works for you.
Step five, when you notice
your mind wandering,
gently return to God's presence.
Key word there, being gently.
People get very frustrated.
Like I'm no good at prayer.
My mind always wanders.
Yeah, of course,
because you're a human being
and I think people feel like
they're alone.
These other people,
they just are,
their minds are like steel traps
and they're just locked
in the presence of the Lord.
No, no, I mean,
maybe the lady who was praying
at that church I was talking about,
she's done it for 20 years,
she seemed real good at prayer,
but for most of us mere mortals,
like of course our minds wander.
It's okay.
The key is don't get judgy, right?
Like, oh, I suck at this.
No, just gently,
just gently return to God's presence.
Yeah, be easy on yourself.
And then finally, step six,
end your prayer time
with gratitude and a smile.
Even if you had to face
some hard things.
Even if, you know,
face some of the feelings
or maybe praying for situations
that are really difficult.
You want to be careful
that prayer doesn't become
just a slog.
So end in this heart posture
of gratitude.
So my kind of heart
is that this year,
I hope more of us
can learn to pray,
learn to connect with God
in that way.
So we're going to transition
to communion.
And one of the beautiful things
as you journey into prayer
you'll learn is that
even things that you don't
classically think of as prayer
can become prayer
when you engage it
in a certain mental mode.
When you are fully
showing up to that.
Suddenly you're present
to yourself
and therefore you're present
to God.
And so kind of my hope
as we come forward
to partake of communion tonight,
to take the body of Christ
in the bread,
and the blood of Christ
in the wine,
is that we could do it
in a posture of prayer.
And that we could go out
from this place
as people learning to pray.
Not just when we're like
literally hands folded
having our prayer time,
but in every moment.
So the red is wine,
the middle, white,
is grape juice.
I didn't mention it last time
and some people were very confused.
And someone almost, I heard,
spit out their wine.
So it wasn't eating.
Don't worry.
And so that's that.
The bread is gluten free.
We also practice
what's called an open table.
Meaning if you're here tonight
and you want to participate,
then you're free to do that.
We're going to form
kind of one line here
and then as people serve,
you'll be able
to kind of branch off
and go to whatever side
you're seated on.
So this is the table.
Not of the church,
but of the Lord.
And it's made ready
for those who love Him
and for those who want
to love Him more.
So come.
You who have much faith
and you who have little.
You who have been here often
and you who have
not been here long.
You who have tried to follow
and you who have failed.
Come.
Because it's the Lord Jesus Himself
who invites you.
And it's His will
that those who want to meet Him
should meet Him here.
Table.
♪♪
For this last song,
we're going to sing one
that I just,
I want to invite you
to just sit back
and practice a moment
of being silent
and maybe checking in
with yourself,
like Brett was talking about tonight.
I love the idea of prayer
as kind of returning home.
And I feel like
it's easy for me
to approach prayer
as like I need to get
to a certain place.
You know,
like it's something
outside of myself.
As opposed to sitting
and returning to
the place where
a Creator knit me together.
I am fully who He made me to be.
And I think in life,
there's so many things
that pull us away from that.
And even our sins,
our struggles,
our judgments of ourself
can take us down paths
that are very far from
the person we began as.
And I would love for us
to kind of engage this song
as sort of a practice
of returning home
to that human
that God knit together.
So you guys,
enjoy this as Gary leads it.
It's one of my favorites.
I went the ways of wayward winds
In the world of trouble and sin
Bought the law from a crooked mind
Not a million rank and file
Worked out where I came from
Somewhere back when I was young
I was a good man's child
I lost the nameless things
My innocence flew away from me
She had had a face from my side
To embrace her pit and fire
But tonight I dream
She's singing over me
Oh Lord my child
Come on home
Hold to me
And I will hold you in my arms
Be joyful dear
There will always
Always be a place
For you at the table
Eternally
Oh
I wonder where I might begin
To hear a voice upon the wind
She's singing faith and singing
The truth
Son there ain't nothing you can do
Listen close and follow me
I'll take you where you're meant to be
Just don't lose faith
So I put my hand upon the plow
And wiped the sweat from my brow
And left a good seed along the way
As I look forward to the day
When at last I see
My father wrote to me
I'm singing oh my child
Come on home
Hold to me
And I will hold you in my arms
Be joyful dear
There will always
Always be a place
For you at the table
Return to me my child
Come on home
Hold to me
And I will hold you in my arms
Be joyful dear
There will always
Always be a place
For you at my table
At my table
Return to me
Thank you guys so much.
And again, thank you for choosing
to spend this evening here with us
together in the presence of a God
who loves you and knows you
and calls you by name.
The lovely people who are serving
communion tonight, Christian and Megan,
are the ones who have a new meetup group.
So if you want to touch base with them
after the service, definitely go up
and let them know.
And again, that's for 20-somethings
or fresh out of high school
or college.
Not really a tight, like, restraint on that,
but definitely reach out to them
or someone else if you are interested.
Also, as you are walking out,
to your right is our giving box,
but there's also a form to fill out.
If you call the table home
and you would like to plug in
with serving communion
or children's ministry or whatever,
fill out that form
because we would love to plug you in
and get to know you more through that.
And again, February 12th,
Bible Sunday.
We will be meeting at 4, not 5.
Go, teams.
And in the same vein as different ways
to pray and acknowledge God
and God's presence and love and goodness,
my meetup group, we meet online,
and we all live in different places.
And so when someone's going through a hard time,
everyone will send pictures of candles
that have been lit
and just in honor of,
I'm praying for you,
and I've lit this candle.
And so, thanks, Stephanie.
She's smiling.
She's here in person tonight.
That's exciting.
But she's the one who always does that.
And so tonight,
as we're thinking about the victims in California
and so many mass shootings,
there's already been 30 this year.
That's more than one a day.
And it's just tragic.
So as I come over to blow out this candle,
if we can take another just collective moment
of silence, deep breath in of love,
exhaling hate and fear,
and just remembering those who are hurting
in all sorts of ways.
Now, I'm going to read over you a benediction,
which is just a prayer for the road,
a blessing for the week ahead.
You can take whatever posture you'd like.
If you would like to continue sitting,
if you want to hold the hand of someone next to you,
or if you want to stand and open your arms,
I'm just going to read this over you.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day,
and it's true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead
with its yet-to-be-determined highs and lows
and everything in between,
go filled with the assurance
that you are the child of God.
You are a child of God.
Go filled with the assurance that you are loved,
you are worthy,
and you are accepted just as you are.
And go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same gifts of grace
and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with.
Peace be with you.
In Jesus' sweet name, amen.
And if you need prayer, I'll be at the back,
and would love to pray with you.
Thank you.
♪
Come on home
Home to me
And I will hold you in my arms
In joy for me
There will always
Always be
A place for you at the table
Return to me
My child
♪
Oh
Return to me
♪